kind of glasses are those those are cool
oh Saint Laurent damn yeah Cheese Louise
yeah Salem Ron are they what what I'm
trying to read that yeah you read them
I'm not gonna lie
has blue just a little nice it's blue
splooged
that's what you call it right did you
say that to the sales guy yeah you're
like well this is the price you're like
well don't tell my wife but I'm
splooging myself it's always nice to
splooge on yourself every
oh it's fun right it's very important to
make luge on yourself always remember
that you know the ladies think St
laurent's just for them but I don't know
some of the boys get up to the little
splooging don't get me wrong I splooge
on my wife too all the time ice blue
jumps like the majority of the time but
sometimes it's important to split on
yourself that's how you stay happy
listen man when's the last time you
spluted yourself